he kind of spearheaded this he the the
the questions and the quest of okay I
need I have some I'm not satisfied with
some answers I'm getting he I was his
sounding board for his spiritual
deconstruction and so I think that I was
you know just kind of along for the ride
honestly because it it I'm not my brain
doesn't work in the same way I was much
more comfortable because I thought it
was working for me I thought that how I
conducted my faith
was more helpful than harmful actually
now I've started to realize over the O
over the past decade that there were a
lot of things that were healthy for me
to shed in terms of um judgment and
shame and how I processed that um but as
a sounding board I I was I was pretty
much just kind kind of like a step or
two behind him in terms of my evolving
beliefs because as we said you know
you're the
the first the the questioning
personally the decision to make a change
in a direction of thought and how you
operate your life is a real personal
thing that could have been a huge wedge
and maybe the end of this partnership
and it you know it started with the
first person I kind of confided in was
my wife and and we've I've seen this so
many times it's very unusual for a
married couple that are both in a
particular faith and one person says
adios most of the time those and in
divorce right the first time I told her
I mean listen we didn't believe that
Evolution happened we we believed that
Adam and Eve were real we you know we we
believe that what is in the book of
Genesis was like
history and so when I was there a moment
where this came where you you had a
Flash and you went wait wait wait wait
uh it was like a I started reading about
this in my early 20s and I but mostly
what I would do is I would go and I
would be like I okay there's there's all
these people s saying that the Earth is
you know 10,000 years old but like every
time I go to a museum they're like this
thing lived millions of years ago I
never never looked into this but I
started reading about it and actually I
started reading from like I I would go
to Christian sources right there's a lot
of Christians who don't believe that
there's a lot of Christians who believe
in evolution right there's a lot of
Christians who believe the world is old
or whatever and kind of accept the
established science and so I would
slowly read these sources and kind of my
view was changing but then when it was
like uh I but that's I don't know how to
reconcile this particular thing about
well if we're if we're have this common
ancestor with chimpanzees and you know
apes and Adam and Eve how do you explain
that I would start asking these
questions and then I would like go to my
pastor go to these other people I would
ask them questions and I didn't get
satisfactory answers and then it just
was like a house of cards that was
slowly falling until I remember writing
in my journal I was journaling at the
time uh I was like I'm pretty sure I
don't believe any of this stuff anymore
right but all along the way I would tell
like when I told my wife that I thought
Evolution had happened she burst into
tears I just want to give you an idea of
what where we come from and the
worldview that we were all sort of held
captive to and so but the funny the
funny thing is is but I never reacted
that way no so I actually start I I I
would meter out the conversation with
Jesse at the time be like she can only
handle so much but link and I would hang
out and I would be like bro let me tell
the last let me tell you the last thing
that I read that really makes me think
that none of this stuff is true um and
you would listen and again you weren't
the kind of guy that was going to go off
and do the research on your own but you
were the kind of guy that was going to
listen to someone who you trusted who
had yeah I I mean I I read a couple of
books too but like you know it wasn't it
wasn't quite as you weren't searching
you weren't he was seeking and sharing
yeah and you were listening and being
much more passive so if he and I value
the security of what I had and I just
felt like there was a lot at stake in
trying to I was like yeah I'm going I'm
going to be here for you and I'm going
to I'm going to lovingly listen and
respond and be a sounding board but what
I'm really going to do is I'm going to
I'm going to try to like say yeah but
let's just kind of Tamp all this down
you know get it out of your system I
think is what I thought at first and so
what was the switch where you went yeah
I mean it was just the preponderance of
it it just kept coming I mean anywhere
you anywhere you look I mean it's like
it just kept coming and I did start
reading other people's accounts of
deconstruction and their reasoning and
and he your wife also a lot of that
resonated did they have this did she
have the same uh she was she was yes
because it was we believed that it would
it would split us up yeah that like the
Biblical teaching that we adhered to was
okay you're not going to stay together
you can't do this without Jesus
basically Jesus holding you together
anyway
[Music]
so